that's right here's my ant-man in the
walls spoiler talk that is a spoiler
warning for anyone who hasn't seen
ant-man in the wasp you visually been
warned and this is just spoiler talk
isn't gonna be a play-by-play as always
in fact in this movie there's just a
couple things I want to talk about that
it wasn't able to talk about my spoiler
free review but with those couple things
I really want to delve into it a bit
more sub spoiler talks every three
minutes could be 20 on it here we go so
basically the premise of this movie is
Hank Pimm's wife has been lost to the
quantum realm we knew that we did that
from the last movie she shrank in
between the molecules of this rocket so
she could take out the rocket the rocky
got taken out but she's been lost to the
quantum realm cuz she kept shrinking
until she wasn't here and now she's
stuck there in the quantum realm so Hank
Pym wants to use his tech to get his
wife back ghost wants to use Hank Pym
tech to siphon the life from Hank PIMs
wife so she can essentially fix herself
and stabilize herself when she was a kid
her dad was doing experiments on the
quantum realm big explosion she got hit
by it so she's in a constant state of
flux where she's being ripped apart and
reformed again at the molecular level
which was this a comic book movie means
she gets to walk through walls and then
you have Walton Goggins he's in this
movie no disrespect to the actor I love
them but it's that arc why too much so
that's the basic breakdown and the
backstory is ghosts when shield was like
hey you can face through walls and you'd
be a great assassin how about this you
can assassinate for us and then we'll
fix you and then shield fell but by that
that means she was around for the
entirety of the MCU it's one of those
scenarios when you create something new
that's been around the whole time and
you kind of create plot holes looking
back not plot holes at least question
mark into sci-fi movies an MCU movie
it's a movie for fun every movie has
those moments where you look at it
you're like does it alright doesn't
really make sense how did the Joker wire
an entire Hospital to blow up in one day
know what I mean every movie has it all
depends on whether or not those moments
compromised your entire experience I
don't think so but if ghost was around
in the world of Captain America Winter
Soldier I imagine shield to be like all
right this guy's causing his problems
instead of sending in the Winter Soldier
let's just send in an assassin that can
go through matter really get the job
done I think we can take him out and
then we can control everything like we
wanted to do in Captain America Winter
Soldier but I guess that was Hydra but
that's the point Hydra had infiltrated
shield so if shield had access to it
Hydra had access to it when is Robert
Redford had access to ghosts at the time
of Kaif
America Winter Soldier so why not send
ghosts in to get the job done instead of
Winter Soldier at the very least might
have saved him a housekeeper kind of
like when you show in a later Star Wars
movie that forced ghosts can just call
lightning and burn things you wonder why
they didn't do that before and that's
the problem with cinematic universes
really you expand them you have to do
new things you have to show new things
but then you're gonna create new things
new tack new characters new people new
abilities that you showcase here and if
the statement or insinuation is well
they've been around this whole time your
audience is going to be like wait a
minute if it was like that the whole
time then why didn't we see them until
now or why didn't we see it until now
they do ask that questions for ghosts
presence in this movie because they've
said she's been around since the MCU has
been around and the leash master of her
is a super government organization
that's responsible for assembling the
Avengers to save the world I feel like
we would have seen her by now every
expanding cinematic universe will run
into this it's all about when they run
into it I do like how Scott Lang was on
house arrest and Hank Pym is essentially
a criminal now because Scott Lang was in
civil war he fought the Avengers people
know Scott Lang as ant-man and they know
the tech is from Hank Pym although Hank
Pym could just be like he stole it point
is there were repercussions from that I
really like that actions have
consequences sometimes those
consequences wash onto other people
that's the reality of life I like that
this movie showed that and I do concede
the fact that ghosts in her mind's eye
isn't a villain but no villain is a
villain in their minds I there are a
couple villains you can argue be like
yeah I know I'm an [ __ ] generally
though every villain is the hero of
their own story so people are gushing
about that with ghosts like yeah but
she's not the villain it's like that's
not new miss the way villains are Zemo
didn't think he was a villain vulture
Adrian Toomes
didn't think he was a villain even
Obadiah Stane in his mind's eye was like
I'm a capitalist this will gain me
profit it's a good weapon I'm not a
villain it's just it's business so
basically long story short
fast-forwarding a bit Scott Lang does go
to the quantum realm and he finds Hank
Pym 'he's wife was funny enough she did
eight I thought she was just still gonna
be young but then they'd have to make
the CGI face on her face and she would
have to be young forever and that
probably be difficult so unexpectedly
she did age and she did say when she was
essentially in Scott Lang's body like
Paul Rudd is Michelle Pfeiffer's
character and typing on the keyboard and
he or she says she's had a lot of time
to think about this so it's been a long
time for her I feel like it's been 30
years for her in 30 years for us I only
mention that because hank pym said at
that sighs the concepts of space-time
that you know they start to
down so the fact that she's
chronologically the same age I feel like
in that world where space of time we're
different they're apparently the same at
least they're similar enough which I
find strange and I'm not gonna Pasha
like I'm some sort of theoretical
physicist I don't know I'm just saying
as I understand it when you get that
small subatomic sub subatomic small
enough if you think of the dimension of
space-time as a screen door you're so
small you're in between the greats of
the screen in which case are you
actually in the realm of space-time I
mean you're not on the screen door
you're in between the screen of the
screen door a space in between spaces on
space if you get small enough that is
and again I'm asking or if the case
would be yes at the size I'm talking
about time would affect them differently
but it didn't maybe they never got as
small as I thought they did actually is
a pretty good discussion said if just
talking about movies and ratings let's
talk about space-time so let's open up
the conversation in the comment section
that's cool doesn't change the fact that
story-wise one of two things happened
here either space and time did affect
Michelle Pfeiffer's character
differently in which case she probably
wouldn't age but she did age which means
it probably didn't it didn't affect her
differently it didn't work differently
for in which case you would have to
sustain her body per normal in an
environment that's not conducive to
sustaining a multi-celled organism the
quantum realm wouldn't you look at it
and I say it disappointed me I'm just
saying it looked a lot like dormammu's
world so I now feel like if they're
going to another world that's not like
our world not like our reality at all
their default is to have little waves
and things building from the ground up
that look like upside down clay or water
oh yeah it's fine do it so they get
Michelle Pfeiffer out of the quantum
realm the FBI agent is kind of a
douchebag I mean if you have to become
ant-man to help someone out I feel like
he can give him a slide on the probation
but whatever Scott Lang fulfills his
probation and all's right with the world
and the thing the dumbest I thought this
was done goes to still she's phasing her
molecules are being torn apart and then
put back together again Michelle
Pfeiffer goes hold on and straight up
et's hearse goes bang ouch and touches
her temples like ouch
and then she's cured it's fine Jesus
touches her touches her head it's your
miracle because what that reminds me of
v like the old series v like one of the
humans one of the reptile aliens had a
baby together who I guess is the star
child she grabs these controllers and
glows and saves the day like the
it was just like they're like we don't
know they're a little goofy to me I mean
I imagine being in the quantum realm
changed her somehow it's just a simple
thing where it's like she needs to
change let's have her have the ability
to heal the villain because it's just
easy we don't need an explanation
suppose it's every bit as good an
explanation as gamma radiation turning
Bruce Banner into the Hulk but for some
odd reason has crossed a line just magic
fingers to healing a girl I just didn't
like it but really with ant-man you have
to look past a lot of physics don't
matter in that man really if you look at
it if you take an object's it's about
six feet tall like ant-man and you
shrink him down object is comprised of
matter and space you condense the space
in between matter you can thereby shrink
the object rather that's from Honey I
Shrunk the Kids but I've always seen
that as the way to shrink an object in a
movie still maintains all the matter in
the mass so when ant-man's that tall
he's a little peg that's a quarter of an
inch tall but he's a hundred and seventy
pounds let's just bring in force with
the fact that they can use momentum and
flip people over when they're small to
imagine a peg that big that's that heavy
let's go right into your lawn but you
look past it for the sake of enjoying
the movie actually holy crap when
there's that kitchen throw down the guy
has the knife for the cleaver is going
after ant-man you gonna stop billing all
right hit me yeah yeah broke your knife
and half didn't you at least chipped it
because I am dense
I'm your density George McFly but in the
end credits scenes the first post-credit
scene is great ant-man is going into the
quantum realm to gather up healing
energy with this device I guess they
have to gather healing energy which kind
of reminded me of the flash you know in
the flash it's always like we have this
problem good news in a day whipped up
this thing that will deal with the
problem and I like to flash haven't seen
the last season of the flash but I like
to flash but that is the thing they do
so he's there and they're like we're
gonna bring you back in three two
nothing be things they're joking with
them and I didn't even think about it
and then it goes to them spoilers for
infinity war if you haven't seen it in
three two one
you see ash falling from without human
height they disappeared they were they
were part of the half that disappeared
when Thanos went like that so now
ant-man stuck in the quantum realm Hank
Pym and his wife they're gone Evangeline
Lilly the wasp
nice knowing you and that's where we
leave off actually I think it'd be
really cool if ant-man was supposed to
disappear but he was so small again he
was in between the realms of reality or
at least he was outside our realm of
reality we didn't get hit with it then
again
radio contact with people in our world
that kind of throws that out if you want
to be creative for a sucker the second
post credit scene is lame it's it's the
aunt playing the drums it's in the
trailer to the movie
that's weird it's like they were like we
need to let's just have an aunt playing
drums of the post-credit scenes that is
my least favorite one I just like the
fact that that infinity war tying in the
post-credits scene I genuinely love that
doesn't make you wonder if there was a
news flash of these big metal space
doughnuts landing in cities over there
part of it totally worked man it didn't
mean to dig into this movie I feel like
the last couple spoiler talks was going
to movie I don't mean for that to be the
case I really enjoyed it it's just some
of the things that gave me pause and at
least gave me a question mark you're
like is that really it spoiler territory
so I figure to talk about him here it
might make this video seem a little
negative overall I don't mean for that'd
be gay but I got to ask some science
questions that's the important thing
about being a fan of science right hey
don't be afraid to ask questions be
concede to the fact that you might not
know what the [ __ ] you talking about and
always err on the side of I'm probably
full of [ __ ] I probably missed something
I'm genuinely curious about it if you
actually know what a hundred percent
know the answer to the question but I
will still not like et fingers so as for
ant-man in the wasp and the quantum
realm and space and time and how it
would affect them at that size as
opposed to them at our size the screen
door metaphor and all that the density
of Ant Man will be small and the mass of
Ant Man being the same if he's big or
small what do you think about any of
that would everything comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you